Fifth grade. It was so long ago. Who can remember that far back? Two whole years.
五年级。那已经是太久以前的事了。谁还能记得那么久远的事呢？整整两年啊。
I remember all of, like, the old things. Like, we used to read the book Harry Potter. And we made curtains.
我记得所有那些旧事物。比如，我们过去常读《哈利·波特》那本书。我们还做了窗帘。
Harry Potter curtains.
《哈利·波特》窗帘。
And, like, they have new curtains now. And I look back at them, and I'm like-- I look at them and I'm like, wow, you know. It's changed. And I wish it was still there somehow.
而且，你看，他们现在有了新的窗帘。我回头看看它们，我就觉得——我看着它们，心想，哇，你知道的。一切都变了。我真希望它还能以某种方式存在。
This is Kayla Hernandez, in seventh grade at the Pulaski School in Chicago. She says she actually visits her fifth grade classroom, room 211, and her fifth grade teacher, Mrs. Chan, fairly often, and reminisces about the past.
这是凯拉·埃尔南德斯，芝加哥普拉斯基学校的七年级学生。她说她实际上经常去她五年级的教室，211室，以及拜访她五年级的老师陈老师，并回忆过去。
Recently I went through the shelves, and our books are still there. Like, Our America.
最近我翻了翻书架，我们的书还在那里。比如，《我们的美国》。
You're talking about the book, Our America.
你说的是《我们的美国》那本书。
Yeah. You know, I'm reminiscing about when we used to read that book, and how it showed lots of racism.
对。你知道，我在回忆我们以前读那本书的时候，它展现了许多种族主义。
Back in fifth grade, she covered her copy of Our America with one of those paper book covers you get. It was her copy, though they're not allowed to write their name in the fronts of books at her school.
五年级时，她用那种常见的纸质书套把她的《我们的美国》包了起来。那是她的课本，尽管在她学校，学生们不被允许在书的封面上写名字。
They had numbers, and my number, I think, was like, 30.
书上有编号，我想我的编号大概是30号。
So you did find book number 30?
所以你真的找到了30号书？
Yeah, I did. I saw the book, and it was just there, without its paperback cover. And everything that was mine is not mine anymore. I think that's the hardest thing from switching to another grade, into another classroom and to another teacher. And there is new environments and new and different things to learn, and old memories to leave behind.
嗯，找到了。我看到了那本书，它就在那儿，没有了纸质书套。曾经属于我的一切现在都不再属于我了。我认为从一个年级转到另一个年级，进入另一个教室和面对另一位老师，这是最难的事情。新的环境和新的、不同的事物需要学习，而旧的记忆则不得不被遗忘。
20 years from now, 30 years from now, when you try to remember back to seventh grade, what do you think you're going to remember from this year?
20年后，30年后，当你试图回想七年级时，你觉得你会记得今年的什么？
I think I'll remember barely anything.
我想我几乎什么都不会记得。
Isn't that kind of strange, though, to think that you're going through all these experiences now that somehow are going to get wiped off the blackboard?
但你不觉得很奇怪吗？想到你现在经历的所有这些体验，以某种方式都会被从黑板上擦掉？
Yeah. But I even have that experience now. Like, I can't remember things from second grade. I see some things. Like, I remember this kid, he wrote this Valentine card for me. It's like, you're pretty as a rose. I don't know. Something like that. But I can't remember teachers really well like I used to.
是啊。但我现在就有这种感觉。比如，我不记得二年级发生的事了。我能看到一些片段。比如，我记得有个孩子给我写过一张情人节卡片。上面写着，你像玫瑰一样美丽。我不记得了。大概是这样。但我已经不像以前那样能很好地记住老师了。
Do you feel sad about that, or is that OK?
你对此感到难过吗，还是觉得没关系？
I feel sad about that, because it's a part of me. It's like you don't even remember what's happened. It's kind of hard because it's been a part of you.
我感到难过，因为那是属于我的一部分。就好像你连发生过什么都不记得了。这有点难受，因为那是曾经构成你的一部分。
When I asked Kayla which of her friends she wouldn't remember at all some day, it wasn't hard for her to answer.
当我问凯拉她将来根本不会记得哪位朋友时，她回答起来并不困难。
Cynthia. I'll probably forget Alíleni. I'll probably forget Diana and Maria. I'll forget Erica Sorio. I'll forget a whole bunch of people.
辛西娅。我大概会忘了阿莉莱妮。我大概会忘了戴安娜和玛丽亚。我会忘了埃丽卡·索里奥。我会忘掉一大堆人。
She's not close to these kids or anything. But as she said their names, it was like watching them vaporize or something. Someday they'll just be gone, erased from the history of her life, like they had never been there in the first place.
她和这些孩子并不是很亲近，什么都不是。但当她说出她们的名字时，就像看着她们蒸发了一样。总有一天她们会消失，从她的人生历史中被抹去，就像她们从未出现过一样。
We forget most of everything. And then sometimes we go back and try to remember. And there really is no predicting which people and places and moments we're going to be able to get back. Diana and Maria, they could still make the cut.
我们几乎忘记了一切。然后有时我们回头试图回忆。真的无法预测我们能找回哪些人、地点和时刻。戴安娜和玛丽亚，她们可能还有机会被记住。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "Return to Childhood," what you find and what you do not find when you go back.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“回到童年”，讲述当你回去时所发现的和未发现的东西。
Our show today in four acts. Act 1, Ich bin ein mophead. In that act, a 34-year-old man investigates who he was at nine years old and learns a thing or two he would just as soon not remember. Act 2, Punk In a Gray Flannel Suit, in which a mortgage broker discovers that the punk band he was in the '70s is hot in Japan and decides to leave corporate life for a little bit and go back on tour.
我们今天的节目分为四幕。第一幕，《我是拖把头》。在这一幕中，一名34岁的男子调查了他9岁时是谁，并学到了一些他宁愿不去记住的事情。第二幕，《穿灰色法兰绒西装的朋克》，讲述了一位抵押贷款经纪人发现他在70年代所在的朋克乐队在日本很受欢迎，于是决定暂时离开职场，重新开始巡演。
Act 3, Ariel Sharon, Shimon Peres, David Ben Gurion, and Me-- an American teenager who dreams of someday being the prime minister of a nation where he does not even reside. Act 4, When We Were Angels, in which we hear the purest possible student uprising imaginable, the most innocent, documented by an actual student using the crudest tools-- a telephone answering machine and a shiny red boom box. Stay with us.
第三幕，《阿里尔·沙龙、希蒙·佩雷斯、戴维·本-古里安和我》——一个美国少年梦想着有一天能成为一个他甚至都不居住的国家里的总理。第四幕，《当我们还是天使时》，我们听到了有史以来最纯粹的学生起义，最天真无邪的起义，由一名真正的学生用最简陋的工具记录下来——一台电话答录机和一个闪亮的红色手提音箱。请继续收听。
Act 1, Ich bin ein mophead. Alex Blumberg was a producer on our program for many years, and back when he was working here-- today's show is a rerun-- he made a decision to return to his childhood. He went searching for somebody named Susan Jordan, who he and his sister Kate and their parents knew for about a year when Alex was growing up in Cincinnati.
第一幕，《我是拖把头》。亚历克斯·布隆伯格曾是我们节目多年的制作人，当他在这里工作时——今天的节目是重播——他做出了一个回到童年的决定。他去寻找一个叫苏珊·乔丹的人，当亚历克斯在辛辛那提长大时，他和妹妹凯特以及他们的父母和苏珊相识了大约一年。
These are the things that I remember about Susan Jordan. Me and her sitting in the back room and telling her about the day camp I went to that summer. I can't get myself to shut up. "And they had alligators and snakes," I can hear myself telling her. "And this one time, this one alligator got out, and the counselor had to catch it," and on and on like that.
这些是我关于苏珊·乔丹的记忆。我和她坐在后屋，告诉她那天我去参加的日间夏令营。我无法让自己闭嘴。“他们有鳄鱼和蛇，”我能听到自己对她说。“有一次，其中一只鳄鱼逃了出来，辅导员不得不把它抓住，”等等，诸如此类。
Me and Susan flipping through one of those Time Life books-- Rock and Roll Through the Decades: The Sixties. She has long brown hair. She's incredibly skinny. It's 1975. She's wearing bell bottom Levis, a faded jean jacket.
我和苏珊翻阅那些《时代生活》丛书之一——《摇滚乐的几十年：六十年代》。她留着棕色的长发。她瘦得惊人。那是1975年。她穿着喇叭腿牛仔裤，一件褪色的牛仔夹克。
Hi, mom.
嗨，妈妈。
Hi, Alex.
嗨，亚历克斯。
Do you want to know why I'm calling?
你想知道我为什么打电话吗？
I do. I do.
想啊，当然想。
You remember Susan Jordan, right?
你记得苏珊·乔丹，对吧？
Susan Jordan. Susan Jordan. Yes, it's ringing a bell, but I can't place it.
苏珊·乔丹。苏珊·乔丹。是的，听着很耳熟，但我记不起来了。
She was our babysitter.
她是我们的保姆。
Oh, OK. Chicken Legs and Mophead.
哦，好吧。鸡腿和拖把头。
One of the many ideas that Susan introduced to our household was the concept of the nickname. I think that's all I want to say about Chicken Legs and Mophead. I'd gone to my mother to fill in gaps in my memory of Susan, but she didn't remember much more than I did.
苏珊引入我们家庭的众多想法之一就是绰号的概念。关于鸡腿和拖把头，我想说的就这么多。我去找我妈妈是为了填补我记忆中关于苏珊的空白，但她记得并不比我多。
She was a babysitter that really had more of a relationship with you two than she did with us. She seemed to have a very meaningful relationship with you, almost the kind of relationship that you might have with another adult. That was about the extent of it. And she never stayed around when I came home. She was out of there.
她是一个跟你们俩的关系比跟我们更好的保姆。她似乎和你们有一种非常有意义的关系，几乎就像你们与另一个成年人之间可能会有的那种关系。这就是全部了。而且当我回家时，她从不留下来。她马上就走了。
What talking to my mom did do was make me look at my childhood memories from an adult perspective-- like, for example, what I remembered about her living situation.
和我妈妈的谈话确实让我从成年人的角度审视了我的童年记忆——例如，关于她生活状况的记忆。
I didn't get the impression that she was close to her family. I got the impression that she was very much out on her own very young. I think she must have been in the process of breaking with her own parents during that time.
我不觉得她和她的家人很亲近。我得到的感觉是，她很小就非常独立了。我想在那段时间里，她一定正在经历与父母决裂的过程。
That's-- yeah. See, my memory is that, like, she was in high school, right? She went to Withrow.
那是——是的。你看，我的记忆是，她是高中生，对吧？她去的是威瑟罗高中。
Yeah, mm-hmm.
是的，嗯。
But I also remember her living on her-- for some reason I remember her own house.
但我还记得她独自生活——不知为什么，我记得她有自己的房子。
Yeah.
是的。
And the reason I thought that she lived by herself was we went to some-- we went to her house or her boy-- we had to go pick something up somewhere, and we were in her car. This big blue Duster, I think it was. And her boyfriend was there, and her boyfriend had let the cats out, and they were gone. And she was furious.
我以为她独自生活的原因是我们去过某个地方——我们去了她的房子或者她的男朋友——我们得去某个地方取点什么，我们坐在她的车里。我想是一辆蓝色的大道奇达斯特。她的男朋友在那里，她的男朋友把猫放跑了，猫不见了。她非常愤怒。
And then I got in the car. And then she slammed the door. And I think we peeled out. And he was sort of standing-- you know, he was sort of standing there and trying to reason with her, and we were out of there.
然后我上了车。然后她猛地关上车门。我想我们开车疾驰而去。他当时有点站在那儿——你知道，他有点站在那儿试图跟她讲道理，而我们已经离开了。
Well, what did you think?
那么，你是怎么想的？
It made me-- I think I felt sad for her. This is sort of in retrospect, but I think I had some sort of inkling of this idea at the time. I'm just sort of now realizing it. But I remember thinking that he was one of the few people that she had in her life, and she couldn't even really depend on him.
这让我——我想我为她感到难过。这算是一种事后回想，但我认为我当时就有某种预感。我现在才意识到这一点。但我记得当时想，他可能是她生命中仅有的几个人之一，而她甚至不能真正依赖他。
Yeah. You were probably right. She was a struggler. And you may have been at that point, at that moment, her only friend, you know?
是的。你可能是对的。她是个挣扎者。在那一刻，你可能真是她唯一的朋友，你知道吗？
My mom didn't have any idea where I could find Susan, which made things difficult. Because A, Susan Jordan is a very common name, and B, it's probably not her name anymore. I called the county court records department to find all the Susan Jordans married in Cincinnati. My mom asked a friend who worked for the city to search all the Cincinnati birth records. I contacted high school alumni associations. I asked friends at high-powered newspapers to run background checks.
我妈妈根本不知道在哪里能找到苏珊，这让事情变得很困难。因为A，苏珊·乔丹是一个非常常见的名字，B，那可能已经不再是她的名字了。我打电话给县法院记录部门，查找所有在辛辛那提结婚的苏珊·乔丹。我妈妈请了一位在市政府工作的朋友去搜索所有的辛辛那提出生记录。我联系了高中校友会。我请求在大型报社工作的朋友进行背景调查。
Finally, there was one former Susan Jordan who stood out. She seemed the right age. She was married, living in a Cincinnati suburb. She had a couple of kids. Her husband was a lawyer.
最终，有一个曾经叫苏珊·乔丹的人脱颖而出。她年龄似乎正好。她已婚，住在辛辛那提郊区。她有几个孩子。她丈夫是一名律师。
I got her number from information. And it wasn't until I sat down to call her that it hit me. A phone call from someone you babysat 20 years ago might not be a welcome surprise, but in fact strange and creepy. Here I am practicing sounding benign.
我从查询台得到了她的号码。直到我坐下来准备拨通电话时，我才猛然醒悟。一个你20年前看护过的孩子打来的电话可能不是一个受欢迎的惊喜，事实上甚至可能显得奇怪且诡异。我在这里练习听起来无害的声音。
One two, one two. Susan. Is this Susan Jordan? Is the Susan Jordan? Oh, god. Oh, god.
一二，一二。苏珊。是苏珊·乔丹吗？是那位苏珊·乔丹吗？哦，天哪。哦，天哪。
Finally, I made the call.
最后，我拨通了电话。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hello. Hi, is this Susan?
喂。你好，是苏珊吗？
Yeah.
是。
Hi. My name's Alex Blumberg, and I'm calling from a radio program called This American Life. And this is probably a very strange phone call to receive, but I was wondering-- first of all, do you remember me?
你好。我叫亚历克斯·布隆伯格，我从一家叫《美国生活》的广播节目打来。这可能是一个非常奇怪的电话，但我想问问——首先，你还记得我吗？
No.
不记得。
It turns out there are a lot of Susan Jordans who don't remember me. A lot. One guy even called his ex-wife, a former Susan Jordan, and then called me back to tell me she'd never heard of me.
事实证明，有很多叫苏珊·乔丹的人都不记得我。很多。甚至有一个家伙打电话给他的前妻，一位以前叫苏珊·乔丹的人，然后回电告诉我她从来没听说过我。
I was getting nowhere by myself. So I contacted a professional, one Irving Botwinick, a certified New York City private investigator. Three days after putting him on the case, I got a message saying he'd found her. I called him back.
我自己什么进展也没有。所以我联系了一位专业人士，欧文·博特维尼克，一位纽约市的注册私家侦探。在他接手案件三天后，我收到消息说他找到她了。我回电给他。
I called her this morning early, roughly around 7:30. I said, good morning, I'd to introduce myself. I said, my name is so and so, and I'm a licensed private investigator in New York, and I'm looking for someone that used to live in Cincinnati and went to a particular school there. And her name at the time was Susan Jordan.
我今天早上很早就给她打了电话，大约在7点半左右。我说，早上好，我想自我介绍一下。我说，我叫某某，我是纽约的一名持牌私家侦探，我正在寻找一个过去住在辛辛那提并在那里上过某所学校的人。她当时的名字叫苏珊·乔丹。
And she said, that's me. And I said, OK. And I said, do you know anybody named Alex Blumberg? And right away, she-- yeah, I babysat for him. And the interesting part about the whole thing is she definitely likes you, remembers you, and she's going to call you.
她说，那就是我。我说，好的。我说，你认识一个叫亚历克斯·布隆伯格的人吗？她马上就说——是的，我当过他的保姆。整件事最有趣的部分是，她绝对喜欢你，记得你，而且她会给你打电话的。
Hello, is this Susan?
喂，是苏珊吗？
Yes.
是。
This is Alex Blumberg.
我是亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
Hi, Alex. How you doing?
嗨，亚历克斯。你好吗？
I'm doing OK. How are you?
我还好。你呢？
Fine. Did you get my email?
挺好的。你收到我的邮件了吗？
I got your email, yeah.
我收到你的邮件了，是的。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
And I called you at work, and then I realized that I'd also gotten this number from the private investigator.
而且我打过电话到你单位，后来我意识到我也从私家侦探那里得到了这个号码。
Susan and I talked for over three hours on the phone, catching up, comparing notes. She asked about my sister and kids that used to live on the street and our old family dog.
我和苏珊在电话里聊了三个多小时，叙叙旧，交换了信息。她问起我妹妹和以前住在街上的孩子们，还有我们家那条老狗。
How are you doing?
你怎么样？
I'm doing OK.
我还好。
It was amazing how much she remembered and how much we remembered in common, even small incidents like the time that we were stopped at the traffic light and I stared too long at the guy on the motorcycle.
令人惊奇的是她记得那么多，我们共同记得的事情也那么多，甚至是一些小插曲，比如我们被交通灯拦住时，我盯着摩托车上的那个人看了太久。
I think I remember that. Was it on Erie Avenue?
我想我记得那个。是在伊利大道上吗？
Probably. Probably. And he said, did he say something to you? And I said, no, he didn't say anything to me. And you said, he said something to you, didn't he? And you were about to get out of the car and kick that guy's ass, I'm sure.
可能是。可能是。她说，他跟你说了什么吗？我说，不，他没跟我说什么。你说，他肯定跟你说了什么，对吧？我敢肯定，你当时正准备下车去揍那家伙一顿。
I think I can remember your face. I think you were sitting very still with your hands in your lap. Were you afraid?
我想我能记得你的脸。我想你当时坐得笔直，双手放在膝盖上。你害怕吗？
I was terrified. Yeah. I didn't know that he would notice me exactly. But, uh--
我吓坏了。是的。我不知道他会准确注意到我。但是，呃——
Well, don't worry. I would have taken him out. I had no fear, I'm telling you.
嗯，别担心。我会搞定他的。我当时什么都不怕，我告诉你。
Do you remember a time-- it was, like, maybe six or seven or eight years after you babysat us. And I was working--
你还记得有一次吗——那是在你照顾我们之后的六、七或八年。我当时在工作——
The grocery store?
杂货店？
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, I remember. In Norwood, right?
是的，我记得。在诺伍德，对吧？
In Norwood, right. At the Thriftway.
在诺伍德，对。在Thriftway超市。
Yeah, I remember. I guess you-- were you bagging my groceries, but I didn't recognize you?
是的，我记得。我想你——你是当时在帮我装杂货，但我没认出你？
I don't--
我不——
And then you told me who you were, and then I did.
然后你告诉我你是谁，然后我就认出来了。
Right, right. I think you said Mophead.
没错，没错。我想你当时叫我拖把头。
Oh my god. I did warp you. Do people still call you that?
噢，天哪。我真的让你变样了。人们现在还那样叫你吗？
No.
不叫了。
Susan got married when she was still in college and went to work for the phone company as a repair person. She spent the next 20 years or so hanging from a telephone pole, she said. She hated it, but the money was good.
苏珊在大学还没毕业时就结婚了，并去电话公司当了一名修理工。她说，接下来的20年左右她都挂在电话杆上。她讨厌这份工作，但薪水不错。
Around the time her first marriage ended, she finally got up the courage to quit and find work using her degree. She now teaches at a special school for mentally ill children. She lives in Florida with her second husband, and she seems happy.
在她的第一次婚姻结束时，她终于鼓起勇气辞职，并利用她的学位找到了工作。她现在在一所专门为患有精神疾病的儿童开设的特殊学校任教。她和她的第二任丈夫住在佛罗里达，看起来很幸福。
Of course, when you dive back into the past like this, you find how partial and incomplete your memory is. First there are the facts you get wrong. Turns out Susan had been a college freshman when she babysat us, not in high school like I thought. My sister remembered she'd ridden a motorcycle. Also not true. And the guy who she got in the fight with over the cats, who in my mind was her hairy '70s boyfriend, turned out to be her roommate's boyfriend.
当然，当你像这样潜入过去时，你会发现你的记忆是多么片面和不完整。首先，有些事实是你记错了。结果苏珊当我们的保姆时是大一新生，而不是像我以为的那样是高中生。我妹妹记得她骑过摩托车。这也不对。还有那个因为猫和她打架的人，在我脑海里那是她那70年代长发飘飘的男朋友，结果竟然是她室友的男朋友。
But besides the facts you change, there are the facts you completely omit. That fight over the cats, Susan had forgotten totally that I'd been there. And it was a little strange because my presence was the only thing she'd forgotten. Other details she remembered fine, even the names of the cats themselves.
但除了那些你改写的事实之外，还有一些事实你完全忽略了。那次关于猫的争吵，苏珊完全忘记了我也在场。这有点奇怪，因为我的在场是她唯一忘记的事情。其他细节她都记得很清楚，甚至连猫的名字她都记得。
Possom and Tom. We were hillbillies, remember? But I can't imagine what I took you over there for.
波森和汤姆。我们当时是乡巴佬，记得吗？但我无法想象我带你过去干什么。
I'm sure it was for-- you know, I think we were just running errands.
我肯定那是为了——你知道，我想我们当时只是在跑腿。
You're so lucky.
你真幸运。
It's funny, because I remember these very particular incidents, and that was one of them. And probably the reason I remember it is because it seemed very significant to you. I think I sensed as a kid that it was really upsetting to you because I think I felt at that time that you didn't really have very many people in your life at that point who you could trust.
这很有趣，因为我记得这些非常具体的事件，那便是其中之一。可能我记得它的原因是因为它对你来说似乎意义重大。我想我小时候就感觉到这对你来说真的很令人不安，因为我觉得那时候我感觉到你的生活中并没有多少你可以信任的人。
Oh, I didn't have hardly anybody. My whole family moved out of town. I had no family at all. Let's see, I moved out the day I graduated from high school, and I was 17 because I started a year early. I just wanted out. And see, I had found out that I got the scholarship. I packed up that night.
哦，我几乎没有什么人。我的全家人都搬出了城。我根本没有家人。让我看看，我高中毕业那天就搬走了，因为我早读了一年，当时才17岁。我只是想逃离。而且你看，我发现我拿到了奖学金。那天晚上我就打包走了。
Why'd you want to get out so bad?
你为什么那么想逃离？
Because my family was dysfunctional. But my mom-- it was pretty bad.
因为我的家庭功能失调。但我妈妈——情况真的很糟糕。
The girl that I lived with-- at that time, she was taking a lot of drugs. And her boyfriend. And every time I would come home, they would always try to get me to take drugs with them or something. And I really didn't do it much at all. And it was tough to come home.
和我住在一起的那个女孩——那时，她吸了很多毒品。还有她的男朋友。每次我回家，他们总是试图诱导我和他们一起吸毒之类的。但我真的几乎没怎么碰过。回家很艰难。
And I guess I must have been suffering a little bit. I really missed my little brothers and my little sister. And they were gone. And I was, I guess, maybe trying to substitute.
我想我当时一定受了点苦。我真的很想念我的弟弟妹妹。他们都走了。我想，我当时大概是在试图寻找替代品。
I think maybe that's one of the reasons that I remember that we remember you so fondly, though, because I think it worked both ways. I think that we felt-- if that did make you feel closer to us, I think that we responded.
我想这也许就是为什么我们记得我们那么喜欢你的原因，尽管如此，因为我想它是双向的。我想我们感觉到——如果那确实让你觉得和我们更亲近了，我想我们是有回应的。
Well, I was desperately-- I guess I was looking for a family, really. But I mean, if only you knew, you probably wouldn't have hired me. But, I mean, people are complicated.
嗯，我当时非常绝望——我想我当时是在寻找一个家庭，真的。但我的意思是，如果你早知道，你可能就不会雇我了。但是，人们都是复杂的。
Now, what I really wanted to do was spend more time with your mom and dad. But I was terrified. I mean, I just couldn't do it. I was too shy. So a lot of times, it was-- I thought they were asking me to stay longer and talk, and I would just run out.
现在，我真正想做的是和你父母多待一会儿。但我太害怕了。我的意思是，我就是做不到。我太害羞了。所以很多时候，是——我以为他们是在让我留下来多聊会儿，但我还是会跑掉。
I'm sure they were.
我肯定他们是那样想的。
And they probably thought, what's wrong with her? But I just couldn't do it.
他们可能在想，她怎么了？但我就是做不到。
So you sort of talk to us instead, it sounds like.
所以听起来你是改跟我们聊天了。
Yes. I was comfortable around kids because I had kids in my family.
是的。我和孩子们在一起感到很自在，因为我的大家庭里有很多孩子。
Every time the subject of her hard times came up, I hear a subtle hesitancy in Susan's voice. At first I thought it was embarrassment, but that wasn't it exactly. It wasn't until we had been talking for hours that I realized what it was. She was waiting for the other shoe to drop.
每次提到她那些艰难日子的主题，我都能听到苏珊声音里有一丝微妙的犹豫。起初我以为那是尴尬，但其实并不完全是。直到我们聊了几个小时后，我才意识到那是什么。她在等着另一只靴子掉下来。
She hadn't forgotten that her past had happened. She'd just forgotten that I'd witnessed part of it. And her fear, it became clear, the one that had been gnawing at her our entire conversation, was that I was calling to say she had damaged me by exposing me to it.
她并没有忘记她的过去已经发生过。她只是忘了我曾目睹过其中的一部分。很明显，她的恐惧——那个在我们整个谈话中一直折磨着她的恐惧——是她担心我是打电话来告诉她，她通过让我接触那些经历而对我造成了伤害。
I don't think I was too kind back then, because there was a lot of turmoil in my life and in my family. And that's what my fear is, that I might have had some kind of negative impact on people. And I know probably I did on a couple people, but they were my age.
我不认为我那时候太善良，因为我的生活和家庭中有很多动荡。这就是我的恐惧，我可能对人们产生了某种负面影响。我知道我可能确实对几个人产生过影响，但他们和我同龄。
But you just want to remember, yeah, I was a babysitter. The kids love me. Blah, blah, blah. But I would be devastated if I heard anything different.
但你只想记住，是的，我当过保姆。孩子们爱我。等等，等等。但如果我听到任何不同的说法，我会崩溃的。
There are parts of your past you don't want to go back to, parts of yourself you don't want to go back to. And for Susan Jordan, the year of her life that I remember is a year she'd just as soon forget.
你过去的部分是你不想回头的，你性格中的某些部分也是你不愿回去的。对于苏珊·乔丹来说，我记忆中她生命中的那一年，是她宁愿遗忘的一年。
And it turns out, I had also done my best to forget what I was like that year. I didn't think of myself this way at all, but Susan Jordan reminded me, in the gentlest terms possible, when I was nine, I was anxious and bookish. I was kind of uptight.
事实证明，我也尽了最大努力去忘记那一年的我是什么样子的。我根本没有这样想过自己，但苏珊·乔丹用尽可能温和的方式提醒了我，当我九岁的时候，我焦虑且书生气。我当时有点紧张。
Not to seem as an insult, but I just kept thinking, these kids don't know how to play. When I went to your rooms, it didn't seem like you had a whole lot of toys. I hope I've got this right, but it just seems like there were mostly books and more educational things.
不是要侮辱，但我一直想，这些孩子根本不知道怎么玩。我去你们房间时，看起来你们并没有太多的玩具。我希望我没记错，但看起来大部分都是书和更多的教育类东西。
I mean, I remember you had planets in your room and a chemistry set. And I didn't remember that Kate had hardly any dolls. You didn't seem quite as playful as other kids that I had babysat. Just more serious in general. So mainly, I think that's what I did, was try to play.
我的意思是，我记得你们房间里有行星模型和化学实验套装。而且我不记得凯特有什么洋娃娃。你们看起来不像我照顾过的其他孩子那样爱玩。总的来说更严肃。所以我认为我主要做的事，就是尝试去玩。
Perhaps the most amazing thing about this whole story is how little our memories had deceived us about each other, even if they had deceived us about ourselves. As Susan said at one point, each of us remembered what we needed to about the other. I needed to remember the part of Susan that she doesn't think about much, her toughness in the face of hardship. She said she mostly remembered a side of my family that I just take for granted-- that it was calm in our house, that there were books, there wasn't much fighting.
也许这个故事中最神奇的事情是，我们对彼此的记忆有多么少地欺骗了我们，即使它们在关于我们自己方面欺骗了我们。正如苏珊一度所说，我们每个人都记住了关于对方需要记住的事情。我需要记住苏珊不怎么思考的那一面，她在面对困境时的坚韧。她说她主要记得我家庭的一面，而我对此视为理所当然——我们的家里很平静，有很多书，没什么争吵。
It was the first time in my life where I had ever seen that people lived differently than the way I lived. And that's what I decided I wanted for myself.
那是我人生中第一次看到人们的生活方式与我的生活方式不同。这就是我决定我为自己想要的东西。
You can try to return to childhood by looking at photos or visiting the old neighborhood or listening to recordings. Or you can find someone who knew you back then, someone you haven't seen since. They still carry within themselves a picture of you that's unclouded by the years in between. They'll remember you better than you remember yourself. And you can do the same thing for them.
你可以尝试通过看照片、拜访老邻居或听录音来回到童年。或者，你可以找一个当时认识你的人，一个你之后再没见过的人。他们身上依然带着一张你的照片，那是一张未被岁月阴霾覆盖的照片。他们会比你自己更好地记住你。你也可以为他们做同样的事。
Alex Blumberg. He did that story back when he was a producer here at our show. Now he runs a podcasting company called Gimlet Media, and he's the host of the podcast Without Fail.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格。他在担任我们节目的制作人时做过这个故事。现在他经营着一家叫Gimlet Media的播客公司，并且是播客《Without Fail》的主持人。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "BROOKLYN ROADS" BY NEIL DIAMOND]
[音乐播放 - 尼尔·戴蒙德的《布鲁克林之路》]
Act 2, Punk In a Gray Flannel Suit. For a long time, David Philp was the president of a mortgage brokerage firm in Beverly Hills. As you might imagine, in Beverly Hills, they handle rather large mortgages. He dresses in beautiful clothes. He's clean cut.
第二幕，《穿灰色法兰绒西装的朋克》。很长一段时间里，戴维·菲尔普是贝弗利山庄一家抵押贷款经纪公司的总裁。正如你可以想象的那样，在贝弗利山庄，他们处理的是相当大的抵押贷款。他穿着华丽的衣服。他看起来干练清爽。
But back in the 1970s, in England, where he grew up, he was in a punk band called the Automatics. They were never really a big commercial success, but they were respected and known in the history of punk by people who care about that kind of thing. And a few years back, through an odd series of connections, he ended up revisiting his teenage years for the first time by going back on tour in a version of his band in Japan. Here's how something like that happens.
但在20世纪70年代，在他成长的英国，他曾在一个叫“自动装置”的朋克乐队。他们从未真正获得巨大的商业成功，但在朋克历史中，他们受到了那些关心这类事物的人们的尊重和认可。几年前，通过一系列奇怪的连接，他最终通过在日本重新巡演他乐队的一个版本，第一次重温了他的少年时代。事情就是这样发生的。
I mentioned it to a client. And I said, well, you know, I played in a punk group when I was a kid. And he said, oh, really? And he's interested.
我跟一个客户提到了这一点。我说，嗯，你知道，我小时候在朋克乐队里玩过。他说，噢，真的吗？他很感兴趣。
And the next day, he sent me a copy of an eBay auction and said, is this you? And I sort of-- so, it was. And I watched this auction. And I watched this price shoot through the roof. And then I began to realize, wait a minute. I'm collectible.
第二天，他寄给我一份eBay拍卖品的复印件，说，这是你吗？我有点——是的，就是我。我看了这次拍卖。我看着价格直线上升。然后我开始意识到，等一下。我成了收藏品了。
Let's get down to brass tacks here. How much were you guys?
我们来谈谈实际问题吧。你们那些东西卖多少钱？
I think that one actually went at $48. I particularly liked looking at all those sort of other groups that were going at $0.25. You know, music business offerings along punk lines that I thought, what a load of old nonsense, at the time. And it was good to see that their records weren't valued years later. I mean, it was--
我想那一张实际上卖了48美元。我特别喜欢看所有那些以0.25美元出售的其他团体。你知道，那些我当时认为简直是无稽之谈的朋克类音乐作品。很高兴看到他们的唱片多年后价值并没有那么高。我的意思是，那是——
Wow. That history came out on the right side.
哇。历史站在了正确的一边。
Yes. That there is a sort of Darwinism in record collecting.
是的。唱片收藏界存在一种达尔文主义。
What happened next?
接下来发生了什么？
I went to go and see Ricky, the drummer. And Ricky collected everything. And he very kindly lent me these two scrapbooks. So I took pictures and things out of there. I just put it up on a-- had a friend put it up on a website.
我去找了鼓手瑞奇。瑞奇收集了一切。他非常慷慨地借给我这两本剪贴簿。所以我拍下了那里的照片和东西。我只是让一个朋友把它们发到了网站上。
And then I got an email from Fi-Fi in Japan saying, oh, I play in a Japanese punk rock band, and--
然后我收到了日本Fi-Fi的一封邮件，说，噢，我在一个日本朋克摇滚乐队演奏，而且——
Fi-Fi's a name of a person?
Fi-Fi是一个人的名字吗？
Yes. And your record changed my life. And he found out through the website that there was an unreleased album. So he asked if he could put me in touch with Toshio Iijima of Base Records. We struck up a deal. And then they said, well, would you come over here and play some gigs to, you know, promote?
是的。你的唱片改变了我的一生。他通过网站发现有一张未发行的专辑。所以他问是否可以帮我联系Base唱片公司的饭岛俊夫。我们达成了一项协议。然后他们说，嗯，你会来这里进行一些演出以推广一下吗？
So you go to tour. How old are you at that point?
所以你要去巡演。那时候你多大了？
45.
45岁。
45 years old. A little bit of gray hair coming in, perhaps?
45岁。也许开始长出一点灰头发了？
A little bit of gray hair coming in. And I really wasn't sure whether I'd still be able to do it, because I hadn't played those songs in 22 years. Not in my shower, not to anyone. I mean, prior to being married-- I mean, I remember dating women for a year who never knew that I played, had ever played.
开始长出一点灰头发了。我真的不确定我是否还能做到，因为我已经22年没弹过那些歌了。不在浴室里，也不对任何人弹。我的意思是，在结婚之前——我的意思是，我记得和女性约会了一年，她们都不知道我弹过吉他，曾经弹过。
It wouldn't even come up?
这甚至不会被提起吗？
It wouldn't come up, really. I mean, I'd have a guitar hanging around, but lots of other guys did too.
真的不会提起。我的意思是，我身边会有一把吉他，但很多其他人也有。
Would you ever pick up the guitar and play for yourself?
你会拿起吉他为自己演奏吗？
Yes. I wrote a lot of songs for my dog during this period.
会。在这期间我为我的狗写了很多歌。
Really? Some of the titles would be?
真的吗？有哪些标题？
"We're Going to the Park" was a big favorite.
《我们要去公园了》是一个大热门。
To be followed by that hit, "Who's a Good Boy?"
紧接着是那首名曲，《谁是好孩子？》
"Oh, What a Good Boy" is actually a--
《哦，真是个好孩子》实际上是——
It is.
确实是。
[PANTING] (SINGING) What a, what a good boy!
[喘气]（歌唱）什么，什么好孩子！
So we went over there, what, October 6. I took my wife, which possibly was a miscalculation. No, it was a good thing to take my wife, because--
所以我们在那里，大概是10月6日。我带了我的妻子，这可能是一个误判。不，带上我妻子是一件好事，因为——
You were approached by dozens of teenage girls?
你受到了几十个少女的接近？
I was getting stopped on the street.
我走在街上会被人拦住。
So what happened the first night you went onstage?
那么你第一晚上台时发生了什么？
Well, there was just the announcement, the light, and sort of a moment's silence, which lasted forever.
嗯，就是宣布开始，灯光，以及一种持续了永恒的沉默时刻。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼]
And then sort of out at the back, I heard the opening riff of "When the Tanks Roll Over Poland." And there was just this whole ignition of energy from the club, in front. And all these kids just started going mad. And it just clicked right in.
然后在后面，我听到了《坦克碾过波兰时》的开场重复段。那一刻，俱乐部前方爆发出了一股能量。所有这些孩子都开始疯狂起来。那种感觉一下就对了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
It felt like I was in an Automatics cover band or something like that, because it was so long ago I didn't feel that association as the writer, though-- because I wrote the material and all that. I didn't have that association as the writer anymore.
感觉就像我在一个自动装置乐队的翻唱乐队里，因为那是太久以前的事了，我没有感到那种作为词曲作者的联结——因为我写了这些材料等等。我不再有那种作为词曲作者的联结了。
See, but I would wonder if, as you sing the songs, the conviction of the writing returns to you and you remember all of the feelings of it. Did that happen?
看，但我会想，当你唱这些歌时，写作的信念是否回到了你身上，你是否记住了所有的感情。那发生了吗？
There's a muscle memory that was there. You know, the movements are all locked in the lyric and the beat and the parts. And as I played them, they all started to come out. And it was just like a sort of-- like being a marionette or something. Here you punch the air. There you sort of bring it, remind the drummer to come down. And there you point at the guitarist for the solo.
有一种肌肉记忆就在那里。你知道，歌词、节奏和部分的动作都锁在里面。当我演奏它们时，它们都开始涌现出来。这就像一种——就像做一个提线木偶什么的。在这里你要挥拳，在那里你要带入，提醒鼓手跟进。在那里你要指向吉他手准备独奏。
Had you've forgotten the thrill of being onstage?
你忘掉台上表演的快感了吗？
Yes, I'd forgotten what it was to have the audience right there.
是的，我忘记了那种有观众在场的感觉。
Before this, had you ever performed a punk show sober?
在这之前，你有没有清醒地表演过朋克演出？
Never. Well, unless I was taking the antibiotics. Not unless I--
从来没有。嗯，除非我在吃抗生素。除非我——
There's so much information contained in such a brief sentence.
在一句简短的句子中包含了如此多的信息。
No, it actually was one of the great paradoxes, really, I suppose, that it was great to do it sober.
不，那实际上是巨大的悖论之一，我想，清醒地做这件事真的很棒。
Were there moments onstage where you felt your age, where you just thought, oh, hey?
在台上有没有时刻让你感到自己老了，让你心想，噢，嘿？
Towards the end, you really feel yourself. Because it's like a sauna up there. I mean, there's so much energy going around, and it's louder than bombs.
临近结尾时，你真的能感觉到自己。因为上面就像一个桑拿房。我的意思是，那里充斥着如此多的能量，声音大得像炸弹。
So your wife had never seen you do this before. There must have been a part of you which felt so pleased that she could see it.
所以你妻子以前从没见过你这样做。你内心一定有一部分感到非常高兴，她能看到这一幕。
Yes. I felt kind of like I'd become this other person. And when I was over there, my life over here seemed to have a sort of almost dreamlike substance. And then, of course, as soon as I got back, the events in October in Japan just began to assume that sort of mantle of dream. I did three shows-- two in Tokyo and one in Kyoto.
是的。我感觉自己好像变成了另一个人。当我还在那里时，我在这里的生活似乎带有一种梦幻般的质感。当然，当我回来后，10月份在日本发生的事件就开始披上那层梦的外衣。我做了三场演出——两场在东京，一场在京都。
And all three, just great?
三场都很棒？
All three sold out. In Kyoto, we set a club record for the largest attendance ever. And it was so packed we couldn't actually get off stage. The only way out was over. I had to sling myself over the audience, and they carried me on their hands back through the crowd and gently deposited me at the stage door.
三场都卖光了。在京都，我们创下了该俱乐部有史以来的最高入场纪录。里面挤满了人，我们甚至无法走下台。唯一的出路是上面。我不得不把自己抛向观众，他们用双手把我从人群中传了出去，轻轻地把我放在后台门口。
So this is your last gig? That was your last gig?
所以这是你最后一场演出？那是你的最后一场演出？
Yes.
是的。
And it ended with the entire audience lifting you up and passing you bodily out and gently depositing you out of the club?
而且它是以整个观众把你抬起来，把你从人身上传出去，并轻轻地把你送到俱乐部外结束的？
Well, not out of the club but to the stage door, yes. It was amazing.
嗯，不是送到俱乐部外，而是送到后台门口，是的。太神奇了。
I don't think I've ever really been lifted by a mob of teenagers and people in their 20s. What exactly is that like?
我想我从没被一群青少年和二十几岁的人抬过。那究竟是什么感觉？
Well, in Kyoto I felt pretty good about it. I'm not sure how I would have felt about it in London in 1977 where the scene was incredibly violent. Whenever you played, you were just as likely to get beaten up as you were to get paid.
嗯，在京都我对此感觉相当好。我不确定1977年在伦敦我会有什么感觉，那里的现场极其暴力。无论你什么时候演奏，你被揍一顿的概率和拿到钱的概率是一样的。
Describe what it was like to come back after the tour.
描述一下巡演结束后回来的感觉。
It was hard for me to get motivated again to do my business after the tour.
巡演结束后，我很难再有动力去经营我的生意。
It just wasn't as thrilling as being on a stage in front of cheering--
它只是不像在欢呼的观众面前舞台上那样令人激动——
Well, not many things are. And it's a bit like-- you know, my dad's generation. You know, after sort of growing up as a kid, being fired on in World War II and all that kind of stuff. It was kind of hard getting it up for working in the shipping industry again. Shortly after I got back, Steve Lillywhite was in town.
嗯，没多少事情是那样的。这有点像——你知道，我父亲那一代。在二战中经历了枪林弹雨长大之后。要让他们重新对航运业的工作充满动力是很难的。我回来后不久，史蒂夫·莉莉怀特就在城里。
And that is?
那是谁？
He was the original producer. And he was also my roommate at the time that all the Automatics stuff was going on. And now he's incredibly successful. He does U2, Dave Matthews, and all that stuff.
他是最初的制作人。他也是自动装置乐队时期我的室友。现在他非常成功。他为U2、戴夫·马修斯等所有人制作音乐。
And anyway, he was in town, he had some time. And so we hung out together for a couple of days. And Hunter was off.
总之，他在城里，他有一些时间。所以我们在一起呆了几天。亨特当时走了。
Hunter, your wife.
亨特，你的妻子。
Yes. Hunter, my wife. So we got to hang out. And we talked a little about the old days. And he told me, you know, Big Paul from Specs does catering. And Nigel from the members is in Australia now. And Walter from the Heartbreakers, he's a stockbroker in Manhattan.
是的。亨特，我的妻子。我们有机会呆在一起。我们聊了一些过去的日子。他告诉我，你知道，Specs乐队的大保罗在做餐饮。The Members乐队的奈杰尔现在在澳大利亚。Heartbreakers乐队的沃尔特，现在是曼哈顿的股票经纪人。
So I think I got to see, we don't get what we deserve. We get what we get. And we have to be OK with that.
所以我认为我看到了，我们得到的不是我们应得的。我们得到的是我们所得的。我们必须接受这一点。
David Philp, lead singer of the Automatics. David is still writing music. He's released several albums since we first did this interview a few years back. A couple of those new songs even became number one hits on the UK charts. His latest album, West of Wherever, comes out in November.
戴维·菲尔普，“自动装置”乐队主唱。戴维仍然在创作音乐。自我们几年前第一次采访他以来，他又发行了几张专辑。其中几首新歌甚至登上了英国排行榜的冠军宝座。他的最新专辑《West of Wherever》将于11月发行。
Coming up, a fascinating day in the life of a future prime minister, maybe. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，是未来总理生活中有趣的一天，也许吧。那是一分钟后，芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "Return to Childhood," stories of people revisiting the past, what they find there, what they do not find there. We first aired today's show a few years back.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来围绕该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“回到童年”，讲述人们重温过去的故事，他们在那儿发现了什么，没发现什么。我们几年前首次播出了今天的节目。
We've arrived at Act 3 of our show. Act 3, Ariel Sharon, Shimon Peres, David Ben Gurion, and Me. Sometimes when we revisit our childhood, it is not very pleasant what we find. Take, for example, our next guest. When he was a teenager, he started reading the biography of David Ben Gurion, the first prime minister of Israel. And one of the things that he learned is that all of his life, David Ben Gurion kept a diary. And the whole package seemed like a good idea-- the job, the diary.
我们来到了我们节目的第三幕。第三幕，《阿里尔·沙龙、希蒙·佩雷斯、戴维·本-古里安和我》。有时当我们重温童年时，我们发现的并不愉快。举个例子，我们的下一位嘉宾。当他还是个少年时，他开始阅读以色列第一任总理戴维·本-古里安的传记。他学到的事情之一是，戴维·本-古里安一生都在写日记。整个方案看起来是个好主意——工作，日记。
"December 3, 1986, Wednesday. Another fascinating day in the life of Adam Davidson. I have a math test tomorrow. I'm going to school early to tutor a girl in my class for the aforementioned test.
“1986年12月3日，星期三。亚当·戴维森生活中有趣的一天。我明天有数学考试。我打算早点去学校给我班上的一个女孩辅导上述的考试。”
"My math class, a joint pre-calculus and calculus class, consists mainly of seniors not especially interested in learning. I guess that I'm the, quote, class expert, unquote, in that I always do the math problems which no one else can. And for this, I'm disliked. I guess that because I apply myself, think clearly, and do a little work as well as some intelligence helping out, I am a geek. In truth, I am far from it."
“我的数学课，一门预备微积分和微积分合班课，主要由对学习不特别感兴趣的高年级学生组成。我想我是所谓的‘班级专家’，因为我总是能做别人做不出的数学题。为此，我被讨厌。我猜因为我应用自己，思考清晰，做一点工作以及一点点的智力帮助，我成了书呆子。事实上，我远非如此。”
When you first read that to yourself, when you first saw it, your reaction was?
当你第一次自己读到这段时，当你第一次看到它时，你的反应是？
It was pure horror.
那是纯粹的恐怖。
Recently, Adam Davidson, an occasional contributor to our program, found his old high school diaries. Adam's mom is Israeli. His dad is American. Adam grew up in New York. Well, his body was in New York. His brain, as the diaries reveal, was somewhere else entirely.
最近，我们节目的客座撰稿人亚当·戴维森找到了他的高中日记。亚当的妈妈是以色列人。他爸爸是美国人。亚当在纽约长大。嗯，他的身体在纽约。他的大脑，如日记所揭示的那样，完全在别处。
I remember when I was writing it, I remember very clearly-- although I don't say this in the diary-- that it was very clear to me that this was the diary of the future prime minister of Israel, me, that I would one day be prime minister, and it would be very important for history, for people to know the deep thoughts of a young Zionist as he prepared his way to lead his nation.
记得我写它的时候，我非常清楚地记得——虽然我没有在日记里说出来——对我来说非常清楚，这是以色列未来总理的日记，我，有一天我会成为总理，这对于历史来说将非常重要，对于人们了解一个年轻的犹太复国主义者在准备领导他的民族时所持有的深层思想将非常有意义。
Now, our regular listeners here on This American Life might remember that you've been on our program describing your experience in Israeli army summer camp.
现在，我们在《美国生活》的忠实听众可能记得，你曾经在我们的节目中描述过你在以色列军队夏令营的经历。
That was right before I started writing this diary.
那就在我开始写这本日记之前。
Read me another.
再给我读一篇。
Sure. Let's see. "There's so much wrong with Jews and Israel that I'm going to have a job ahead of me. One thing is the lack of any strong Jewish identity among most Jews. This attitude sickens me.
当然。让我看看。“犹太人和以色列有太多问题，我前面有一项工作。其中一件事是大多数犹太人缺乏任何强大的犹太身份认同。这种态度令我作呕。”
"You Jews of the world, stop worrying about money and well-being. I do not know what exactly I'll do. But if this situation continues when I'm a bit older, then watch out, world Jewry, here comes Adam." And "Watch out, world Jewry, here comes Adam" was all in capital letters.
“你们全世界的犹太人，别再担心金钱和安逸了。我不知道具体我会做什么。但如果这种情况持续到我长大一点，那么，当心了，全世界的犹太人，亚当来了。”而且“当心了，全世界的犹太人，亚当来了”全是用的连字符大写字母。
Wow.
哇。
Yep.
是的。
It's interesting that you actually are addressing a readership.
很有趣，你实际上是在针对一个读者群体。
I know. I know. That's what's kind of amazing.
我知道。我知道。那才叫惊人。
And that readership is world Jewry.
而那个读者群体是全世界的犹太人。
Right. Yeah. The Jews of the world will one day read this book and will say, if he knew this at 16, how could I be living so badly?
对。是的。全世界的犹太人有一天会读到这本书，他们会说，如果他在16岁时就知道这一点，我怎么能活得这么糟糕？
Can I ask you to just read one of the passages where you talk about Israel?
我可以请你只读一段你谈论以色列的段落吗？
Sure. Let's see. I mean, I have this thing from January 4, 1987.
当然。让我看看。我是说，我这里有1987年1月4日的一段。
"I memorized 'The Hope,' 'Hatikvah,'" which is the Israeli National anthem, "a few minutes ago. That will help me in Israel." And I find that really amazing that here I am, the future prime minister of Israel, and one of the things I need-- oh God, I need to know the national anthem. I'll probably be called upon to recite that at some point.
“我刚才背下了《希望》，即《Hatikvah》，”这是以色列国歌，“几分钟前。那会在以色列帮到我。”我发现这真是太惊人了，身为以色列未来总理的我，我需要做的事情之一——噢，天哪，我需要知道国歌。我在某个时候可能会被要求背诵它。
There will be a ballgame or something where you just stand up and sing it.
会有一场球赛什么的，你需要站起来唱它。
Right, exactly.
对，没错。
"January 14, 1987. Wednesday. I'm getting more and more angered by the effects of Arab propaganda. They blame the Jews for everything. And the world, including Jews, go along with it. Entirely ridiculous."
“1987年1月14日，星期三。我越来越对阿拉伯宣传的影响感到愤怒。他们把一切都归咎于犹太人。而世界，包括犹太人，都随声附和。完全可笑。”
I mean, I really thought this was a testament for the ages. I really thought that this writing was powerful and persuasive, and anyone who would read it would immediately become a Zionist.
我的意思是，我真的认为这是一个时代的见证。我真的认为这种文字有力且具有说服力，任何读到它的人都会立刻成为犹太复国主义者。
At 16, I had such an inflated sense of myself. There was so much going on in my life then that I can remember, and I wasn't recording it. Instead, I was creating this ridiculous fantasy of, you know, I'm not just a 16-year-old kid who's having crushes and a hopeless geek who can't get a girl to kiss him and being scared and confused about growing old. I'm the future prime minister of Israel, and everything goes through that. But I don't know. I mean, just--
16岁时，我对自己有一种夸大的感觉。那时我的生活中发生了很多事是我记得的，但我没有记录下来。相反，我正在创造这个荒谬的幻想，你知道，我不只是一个正在暗恋、一个得不到女孩吻、对变老感到害怕和困惑的无望书呆子的16岁孩子。我是以色列未来的总理，一切都围绕着这一点。但我不知道。我的意思是，只是——
But maybe keeping a diary where one tells the truth, maybe that's a luxury of being a certain kind of person in a certain kind of situation. Maybe other people in another kind of situation need to actually make up a little fantasy.
但也许坚持写一本说真话的日记，那是一种处于某种境地的人才有的奢侈。也许处于另一种境地的人需要真的编造一点幻想。
Yeah. I think I didn't have much angst about being the future prime minister of Israel. I was very calm and confident and comfortable with it. And I had so much angst about every other aspect of my life. And so I now see it as just kind of-- maybe it was a good solution. It was a good way to deal with what I was going through, to have this space where I could just be one of the greats.
是的。我想我对成为以色列未来的总理没有任何痛苦。我对此非常冷静、自信且自在。而我对自己生命的其他每一个方面都有很多痛苦。所以，我现在把它看作只是一种——也许那是一个好的解决方案。这是处理我所经历的事情的一种好方法，拥有这个我可以成为伟大人物之一的空间。
I wonder what the 16-year-old Adam Davidson would feel in knowing that finally an audience of a million people was getting some of the reading from this diary.
我想知道16岁的亚当·戴维森在知道最终有一百万观众正在阅读这本日记时会是什么感觉。
I think this would feel so small to that 16-year-old. This would feel so nothing. I mean, I remember I was very disappointed and very sad about my parents. I mean, I was reading biographies, of course, of all the prime ministers of Israel.
我觉得对于那个16岁的孩子来说，这感觉太渺小了。这会感觉什么都不是。我的意思是，记得我当时对我父母感到非常失望和悲伤。我的意思是，我当时当然在读所有以色列总理的传记。
And I would just think about my parents and just think, how do you wake up every day knowing that your actions won't affect millions of people? Like, how is that enough motivation just to have your petty little craft and your petty little family and your small little apartment? You know, it just seemed pathetic. And I mean, they have the kind of life that, I mean, basically I want my for myself.
我会想到我的父母，心想，你每天醒来怎么能知道你的行为不会影响数百万人？那种只是有你的小生意、你的小家庭和你的小公寓，怎么能作为足够的动力呢？你知道，这看起来太可怜了。我的意思是，他们那种生活，基本上我想为自己追求的。
What you're saying, though, is that the 16-year-old you would be cringing at your 30-year-old version, just as your 30-year-old version is cringing at the 16.
虽然，你所说的是16岁的你会对30岁的你感到尴尬，就像30岁的你对16岁时感到尴尬一样。
Yeah, that's very true. Yeah, he would be very, very disgusted if he heard this radio piece. It would seem like I had settled in a pathetic way.
是的，那是非常真实的。是的，如果他听到这段广播节目，他会非常、非常厌恶。那看起来就像我以一种可怜的方式安顿了下来。
Adam Davidson. These days, he's a staff writer for The New Yorker.
亚当·戴维森。如今，他是《纽约客》的撰稿人。
Act 4, When We Were Angels. This story originally came to us from a graduate student. Hillary Frank was studying drawing at the New York Academy of Art, and she mailed our radio show a story that she wanted to get onto the program.
第四幕，《当我们还是天使时》。这个故事最初来自一位研究生。希拉里·弗兰克当时在纽约艺术学院学习绘画，她给我们广播节目寄来了一个她想在节目中播出的故事。
And what she had done is that she had recorded the interviews using her little microcassette answering machine. And then to edit the quotes that she had gotten, what she would do is that she would record by dubbing and recording onto her shiny red boombox. It was crude, yes, but the story sounded remarkably like a story from This American Life.
她所做的是用她微型录音机的答录机录制了采访。然后为了编辑她得到的引文，她会做的是通过翻录并录制到她闪亮的红色手提音箱上。是的，这很简陋，但这个故事听起来非常像《美国生活》的故事。
Now, for one reason or another and time considerations, that unsolicited story never made it onto the radio. For this week's show, however, we had her put together another story using that same style which we added music to here at the radio station to make it fully sound like a story on our show. It's a story about an incident that happened to her back when she was an undergraduate.
现在，由于某种原因和时间考虑，那个未受邀请的故事从未登上电台。然而，对于本周的节目，我们让她用同样的风格编排了另一个故事，我们在这里的广播电台添加了音乐，使它完全听起来像我们节目中的故事。这是一个关于她本科时期发生的一件事的故事。
Tufts University is a pretty straight place. Entertainment for most people means fraternity keggers. It's not the sort of place you'd expect people to watch a guy sitting on another guy's shoulders pretending to be a giant. It happened by accident in 1994. My friend Scott was the top half.
塔夫茨大学是一个相当古板的地方。对大多数人来说，娱乐意味着兄弟会的啤酒派对。这不是你会期望人们看一个家伙坐在另一个人肩膀上假装自己是巨人的那种地方。它在1994年意外地发生了。我的朋友斯科特是上半部分。
It was the beginning of the school year, and we were kind of bored one night. And we decided to go up to the quad. And I guess basically Jeff got up on someone's back, and he started yelling and screaming about how giant he was, and how magnificent he was.
那是学年开始的时候，有一天晚上我们有点无聊。我们决定去方庭。我想基本上杰夫爬到某人的背上，他开始大喊大叫关于他有多巨大，他有多宏伟。
And I think actually right after that I might have gotten on someone's back and said, yeah, I am also giant. And I guess that really struck a chord in me. I thought that was pretty amusing. I guess I thought a lot about it. It actually did start me thinking along a particular path.
而且我想实际上就在那之后，我也许爬到了某人的背上说，是的，我也是巨人。我想这确实触动了我。我认为那相当有趣。我想我对此思考了很多。它实际上确实让我沿着特定的路径开始思考。
Scott talked about the idea one night in the dining hall. The next day, on the way to class, he saw signs all over campus that said in bold print, "I am nine feet tall. Come see Giant Man, 8:00 PM on the quad."
有一天晚上在食堂，斯科特谈到了这个想法。第二天，在去上课的路上，他看到校园里到处都是用粗体字写的标语，写着“我九英尺高。晚上8点来方庭看巨人侠。”
Scott had no idea who put them up. He learned later that the signs were posted by a guy who had overheard him talking at dinner. Scott decided he would go to the quad at the specified time and undertake the challenge. To pull this off, he would need to create a character and a costume for the giant. He gave Giant Man a booming voice.
斯科特不知道是谁贴的。他后来才知道，标语是一个在他吃晚饭时偷听到他谈话的家伙贴的。斯科特决定在指定时间去方庭接受挑战。为了完成这件事，他需要为这个巨人创建一个角色和服装。他给了巨人侠一个洪亮的声音。
I don't even know exactly. It was something like, you know, behold! I am Giant! Just this-- not even loud but just kind of weird and suggesting man-ness in some vague way. You know? I don't know.
我甚至不知道准确是什么。类似于，你知道，看哪！我是巨人！就是这种——甚至不是大声，只是有点奇怪，并以某种模糊的方式暗示着人的本质。你知道吗？我不知道。
Scott asked his tallest friend, Podo, to ask as Giant Man's legs. They grabbed some props before heading up to the quad-- a blanket to wrap around their middle to hide Podo, a long wooden staff, and a black curly wig, like the guys in Kiss.
斯科特让他最高的朋友波多作为巨人侠的腿。他们在去方庭之前抢了一些道具——一条毯子裹在中间隐藏波多，一根木制的长棍，还有一个黑色的卷发假发，就像Kiss乐队那些家伙的一样。
We picked out a point in the bushes, Podo and I, and we kind of really couldn't see what was going on out on the quad. And so the time came, and I got on his shoulders, basically, and tied the blanket around my waist, and we walked out.
我和波多在灌木丛里选了一个点，我们真的看不见方庭上发生了什么。所以时间到了，我爬到他肩膀上，基本上，把毯子系在腰上，我们就走出去。
And I remember there just being maybe 10 people, 15 people. And I remember them being way on the other side and sort of running. And what was so ridiculous about it was, there was just a handful of people. And they were so spread out, but they were all sort of coming towards me. It was like, what the hell am I doing here?
而且我记得只有大概10个人，15个人。而且我记得他们都在另一边，正在跑过来。最可笑的是，只有几个人。而且他们散得很开，但他们都朝我走来。那就像，我在这里干什么鬼？
He decided to plan another Giant Man appearance the following week. They posted more signs and told everyone they knew, go see Giant Man, it'll blow your mind.
他决定计划下周巨人侠的另一次亮相。他们贴了更多标语并告诉了他们认识的每一个人，去看看巨人侠，这会让你大吃一惊。
Word spread quickly, and amazingly they were able to keep it secret that they themselves were Giant Man. Most students believed there was an actual nine-foot man come to Tufts for some mysterious reason. I was friends with these guys, and I didn't even know yet.
消息传播得很快，令人惊讶的是，他们能够保密他们自己就是巨人侠。大多数学生相信有一个真正的九英尺高的人因为某种神秘原因来到了塔夫茨。我是这些家伙的朋友，我甚至还不知道。
At the next appearance, almost 200 people were waiting for Giant Man and chanting his name. It was like a political rally. Some of them carried signs that said things like, "We love you, Giant Man," "Why are you here," "Save us from ourselves, Giant Man," "Nine Feet of Lovin'," and "Giant freak, go home."
在下一次亮相时，几乎有200人在等待巨人侠并齐声高喊他的名字。那就像一场政治集会。有些人带着标语，写着诸如，“我们爱你，巨人侠”，“你为什么在这里”，“救救我们，巨人侠”，“九英尺的爱”，“巨人怪胎，回家吧”。
Giant Man made his way onto the quad, and the crowd went wild. People came rushing out of their dorms to see what was going on. When Giant Man reached his fans, he made a small speech. "I am giant," he boomed. "I am huge, and I have brought you butterscotch." He then threw cellophane-wrapped butterscotch to the crowd, and they dove for it.
巨人侠走上方庭，人群疯狂了。人们从宿舍里冲出来看发生了什么。当巨人侠到达他的粉丝面前时，他做了一个简短的演讲。“我是巨人，”他声音洪亮地说。“我巨大无比，而且我带给你黄油糖果。”然后他向人群抛洒用玻璃纸包裹的黄油糖果，他们蜂拥而上抢夺。
On the walk up, I just stopped in the bookstore and saw some candy. And I was starting to think, what was the most ridiculous candy that nobody ever ate? And there was butterscotch there and some kind of cellophane wrapper. It looked like nobody was eating it.
在走上去的路上，我刚好在书店停下来，看到了糖果。我开始思考，什么是最没人吃的可笑糖果？书店里有黄油糖果和某种玻璃纸包装。看起来没人吃它。
Butterscotch became Giant Man's trademark treat. When he ran out of things to say, he would revert to throwing candy. The fact of the matter is, Giant Man had very little to tell the Tufts community other than, "My strength is amazing, my girth is enormous, and my height is unequaled." He would brag like this for only two or three minutes and then retreat back to the bushes.
黄油糖果成了巨人侠的标志性招待。当他没什么可说时，他会回归到扔糖果。事实上，巨人侠除了“我的力量惊人，我的身躯巨大，我的高度无与伦比”之外，没别的话告诉塔夫茨社区。他只会这样吹嘘两三分钟，然后退回灌木丛。
The problem was Podo would get really tired really quickly. Like, he walked out really fast, like he almost was running out. And he got really tired and didn't even know where he was going. And he kind of just-- I mean, it must have looked absolutely idiotic.
问题是波多会很快变得很累。比如，他走得很快，就像他几乎是跑着出去的。而且他变得很累，甚至不知道自己在往哪走。而且他只是——我的意思是，那看起来一定绝对像白痴。
So he couldn't see?
所以他看不见？
Yeah. I mean, his eyes were covered. I remember, I would sit on his head and I would put both my hands on his head, kind of give him direction by maybe forcing his head in a certain direction.
是的。我的意思是，他的眼睛被遮住了。记得，我会坐在他头上，把双手放在他头上，通过可能强迫他头的特定方向来给他指示。
Giant Man became a phenomenon. Enthusiasts wore "I Love Giant Man" T-shirts, which had silhouettes of a huge man with a bulging middle. There was once a parade across canvas with noisemakers and a trumpet to greet him. Another time there were torch jugglers and bodyguards.
巨人侠成了一个现象。爱好者们穿着“我爱巨人侠”的T恤，上面有巨大男人的轮廓，中间凸起。有一次，校园里甚至举行了游行，有噪音制造器和小号迎接他。另一次还有玩火球的人和保镖。
Letters were written to the student newspaper, pro and con Giant Man. Teachers were mentioning Giant Man in class. There was a discussion in an ethics course in which people who hadn't seen Giant Man argued about whether or not we were exploiting a freak of nature.
学生报纸收到了支持和反对巨人侠的信件。老师们在课上提到了巨人侠。在伦理课程中进行了一场讨论，没有见过巨人侠的人争论我们是否正在利用大自然的怪胎。
I remember, I was out there. There was this guy that I kind of vaguely knew who was there with a bunch of his buddies. I guess we were from the same fraternity or something. And they were jumping around and stuff. And they're saying, yeah, we're going to take Giant Man down.
记得，当时我在那里。有一个我大致认识的家伙和他的伙伴们在那里。我想我们是同一个兄弟会的什么的。他们蹦蹦跳跳之类的。他们说，是的，我们要把巨人侠拉下来。
When I went out there, I was talking for a little while. And I saw him. He was sort of right behind me, or they were coming up from the side, him and his buddies.
当我走出去时，我聊了一会儿。我看到了他。他就在我身后，或者他和他的伙伴们从旁边过来。
And I remember him just sort of coming up and starting to pull on my sheet and stuff. And one of them tried to push me. And Podo, who could barely stand as it was, after walking out there and with me on his shoulders, he was sort of shaking a little bit and managed to stay on his feet.
而且我记得他只是走过来开始拉我的床单之类的。其中一个人试图推我。波多，本来就几乎站不稳，走出去而且我坐在他肩膀上后，他在颤抖，竟然设法保持站立。
I remember just sort of offering them butterscotch and just screaming about how much I loved them. And they just kind of took off, and it was over.
记得只是给他们黄油糖果，并尖叫着我有多爱他们。他们就走了，结束了。
Do you think that if Giant Man had been an actual political cause that you would have gotten such a big turnout and there would have been such a big deal about it?
你认为如果巨人侠是一个真正的政治事业，你会得到这么多人参加，这会成为一件大事吗？
Yeah, I doubt that. I mean, if there was really-- that's one of the things I think that was a big draw about it was that, you know, it didn't have any meaning. And for whatever reason, people were really drawn to that. I mean, if it had meaning or was trying to pitch some ideas or something, it would kind of seem less real, I think. I mean, there was really something fundamentally interesting and truthful about Giant Man, I guess. I mean, there is something that people are drawn to, to that absurdity, for whatever reason.
是的，我表示怀疑。我的意思是，如果真的是——我认为那是吸引力大的原因之一是，你知道，它没有任何意义。不管出于什么原因，人们真的被它吸引了。我的意思是，如果它有意义或试图推销某种想法什么的，我想它看起来就没那么真实了。我的意思是，巨人侠身上真的有一些根本上有趣和真实的东西，我猜。我的意思是，不管出于什么原因，人们确实被那种荒谬所吸引。
By the end, Giant Man's following had grown to about 350 people. I don't think any of us have had any experience like it since. When you're a student, it still feels like something exciting might happen at any moment. Life feels full of all this potential. But when you get out of school, that potential just doesn't seem to be there.
最后，巨人侠的追随者增加到了大约350人。我想我们之后再没有任何像那样的体验。当你还是个学生时，仍然觉得随时都可能发生令人兴奋的事情。生活看起来充满了所有这些潜力。但当你走出校园，那种潜力似乎就不存在了。
What do you do now?
你现在做什么？
Well, I'm an engineer.
嗯，我是工程师。
What kind of engineer?
什么样的工程师？
A computer engineer, designing computer circuits and things like that.
电脑工程师，设计电脑电路之类东西的。
And do you have Giant Man-like experiences today?
你现在有像巨人侠那样的体验吗？
No. I mean, not really. I'm not parading around talking about my magnificence.
没有。我的意思是，并没有。我没有游行到处去谈论我的宏伟。
There's actually a recording of Giant Man's final public appearance. There was a band called the Electric Fun Machine that dedicated a song to him, and he appeared with them at a concert on the quad.
实际上有巨人侠最后一次公开露面的录音。有一个叫Electric Fun Machine的乐队为他献唱了一首歌，他在方庭的一场音乐会上与他们一起出现。
Giant Man! Giant Man! Giant Man!
巨人侠！巨人侠！巨人侠！
Students of Tufts, fear me not! For I am the benevolent Giant Man! I have come to show love! As a symbol of my benevolence, I shall once again shower you with--
塔夫茨的学生们，别怕我！因为我是仁慈的巨人侠！我来展示爱！作为我仁慈的象征，我将再次向你们抛洒——
And then, Giant Man threw butterscotch candy.
然后，巨人侠抛洒了黄油糖果。
Hillary Frank. In the years since she first did this story for us, she has created many radio stories and a podcast called The Longest Shortest Time, which is about parenting. Her most recent book is Weird Parenting Wins.
希拉里·弗兰克。自从她第一次为我们制作这个故事以来的几年里，她创作了许多广播故事和一个关于育儿的播客《最长的最短时间》。她最近的书是《怪异的育儿胜利》。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "SEPTEMBER SONG" BY BRYAN FERRY]
[音乐播放 - 布莱恩·费瑞的《九月之歌》]
Well, today's program was produced by Jonathan Goldstein and myself with Alex Blumberg, Starlee Kine, Erin Yanke, and Annie Baxter, and mixed by Jared Ford and Catherine Raimondo.
嗯，今天的节目是由乔纳森·戈尔茨坦和我自己，以及亚历克斯·布隆伯格、斯塔莉·凯恩、艾琳·扬克和安妮·巴克斯特共同制作，并由杰瑞德·福特和凯瑟琳·雷蒙多混音。
Senior producer of today's show was Julie Snyder. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Anna Martin. Musical help today from Mr. John Connor. Special thanks today to Lawrench Weschler, Lacey Kine, Craig Danwire, and Anaheed Alani. This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。制作协助来自安娜·马丁。今天的音乐协助来自约翰·康纳先生。特别感谢劳伦奇·韦施勒、蕾西·凯恩、克雷格·丹怀尔和阿纳希德·阿拉尼。本节目由公共广播交换中心PRX发行。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he's been rereading the Bible and talking about it with me in the break room. I don't know about his interpretation of the Bible. Like, OK. God creates two people to live in the Garden of Eden. I really don't think he says--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他最近在重读圣经，并在休息室跟我讨论它。我不确定他对比圣经的解读。比如，好吧。上帝创造了两个人住在伊甸园。我真的不认为他说——
Watch out, world Jewry. Here comes Adam.
当心了，全世界的犹太人。亚当来了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。